we start in afghanistan where the city
of mazai sharif has been captured by the
taliban it was the government's last
northern stronghold the taliban now
control more than two-thirds of the
country you can see those areas in red
the yellow areas are still contested and
the small patch of blue is what remains
in the hands of the afghan government
the taliban's rapid advance comes less
than three weeks before the united
states is set to withdraw its last
troops and is raising fears of a full
takeover by the insurgents
and for more on what's happening in
afghanistan we are joined now by omar
samad he's a former senior adviser to
the chief executive of afghanistan and
the former afghan ambassador to canada
and france mr samad thanks so much for
joining us today the taliban have
tightened their grip on afghanistan at a
frightening pace
is the capital kabul likely to fall and
what will that mean for the nation
uh yes so uh
i think this is what's called the
blitzkrieg
a very fast
progress towards cities capturing cities
one after the other mostly without much
fighting going on either surrendering or
fleeing or deals me being made between
authorities and officials
from governors and
police chiefs and others but your
question about kabul it all depends on
the decision that will be taken in kabul
by president ashraf hani in his team of
close advisors today they met
apparently the president is not still
ready to step down in order to pave the
way for an interim government a
transitional period for afghanistan that
would probably save kabul from any
patch of attack the taliban don't seem
to want to attack from what we hear but
if they are left with no other options
they might use other
means
other cities fell with almost no
no shooting going on very little
casualties
kabul is going to be different and
there's also jalalabad in the east that
also
is an issue right now
would you say that the abruptness of the
u.s withdrawal started by donald trump
continued by uh u.s president joe biden
contributed to the speed of the afghan
collapse to the taliban that we're
witnessing right now
well some people would call it
abruptness uh that has lasted three and
a half years other would call it others
would call it a 20 a 20 year mission
that went on for too long could not
accomplish all its goals
made you know some gains there were some
positive things that happened in the
past 20 years for the afghan people
overall i think that we ended up with a
corrupt government that was
out of touch and disconnected from its
people i think that we hurt that on
people quite a bit as well along the way
and we let corruption take over at the
same time the taliban took advantage of
this
vacuum and this
uh these uh
disenfranchisement in dissatisfaction
and became emboldened and they had
support of of course in the region as
well and now we are where we are after
20 years of a mission in three years
after starting the peace fossils
now the the vast majority of afghans who
are fleeing this conflict are women and
children we're hearing talk of a
humanitarian crisis can you describe to
us the dangers that women and children
in particular are facing
i i hope that we will not face a
humanitarian crisis i hope that on one
hand uh with 80 90 of the country now on
the taliban that they will
uh treat
afghans humanely that they will
abide by laws that they will make sure
that their
core human rights are protected at the
same time we need to make sure that the
afghans who have been displaced from a
few provinces are going to receive
assistance the international community
needs to still be committed to
afghanistan especially on the
humanitarian side from now on
and i think that this is an opportunity
to see how afghans can
reown their own country and rebuild
their own country
to the extent that they can and
hopefully the international community
can assist as well for that to happen we
first need a political settlement
there have been peace talks going on
between the afghan government and the
taliban and qatar they remain stalled do
you think that they have a future is a
peaceful resolution possible at all
well um i think that
that particular process is still
valid and could be of help if
depending on what happens in kabul again
so if in kabul we have a
series of decisions that will lead to a
transition then the transition may
decide that
athon negotiations need to start in
earnest not on like the way we have seen
it happen over the last couple of years
that real negotiations between the
taliban and all our afghans
maybe minus mr valley will happen and
that if that is the case maybe the venue
will change from doha to afghanistan and
so the afghans will sit down in their
own country and discuss the future
political and economic and social order
omar samad the former senior adviser to
the chief executive of afghanistan and
former afghan ambassador to canada and
france thank you so much for your time